half of Ukraine's grain exports crossed
the Black Sea to Nations around the
world but after July's attack on the
Kirsch Bridge linking Russia and Crimea
they stopped that's when Moscow quit a
deal with the U.N and turkey to ensure
safe Passage
Ankara is now seeking to persuade Russia
to return to the agreement under which
Odessa seaports shipped tens of millions
of tons of grain the two men last met in
Sochi just over a year ago after the
grain deal was reached now the Russian
president is refusing to allow safe
passage for more than 20 percent of the
world's grain Supply
President Putin says the agreements
enriched Western businesses and promises
made to exempt Russia exports from
sanctions have been broken a sentiment
echoed by the Russian foreign minister
during a meeting with his Turkish
counterpart in Moscow last week
nearer as soon as measures are taken to
solve all those issues that have
remained unfulfilled despite the promise
of the U.N Secretary General whose
efforts are appreciated as soon as the
talks turn into concrete decisions we'll
be ready to resume our part of the grain
deal the same day
those measures Moscow wants include the
reconnection of the Russian agriculture
Bank to the Swift International payment
systems that was cut off by the EU in
June last year
and although Russia's grain and
fertilizer exports are not subject to
Western sanctions it says curbs on
payments insurance and Logistics are
hampering shipments and it wants them
lifted the U.N Secretary General says he
has sent a letter to the Russian foreign
minister urging resolution we believe
that the Black Sea initiative has given
a very important contribution to make
the Food Markets more
adequate to our objectives of food
security but Russia's foreign minister
says nothing in this new proposal
guarantees Russia's demands will be met
President Vladimir Putin's summer
residence Butcher of roce an imposing
Stalin era Palace near here is where he
will host his Turkish counterpart on
Monday a historic location for a grand
event as a Turkish president seeks to
restore order and convince the Russian
president to agree to a new deal
his failure or success will have Global
consequences
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Sochi